طبعا انا حاولت اخش داخله كلها غموض بس كل
اللي انا كنت بفكر فيه ان انا ما اقعش
وانا طالع على السيتش هم طلبوا منكم حاجه
قبل ما نبدا بالنسبه
طلبه منكم انكم تقعدوا بس انا هطلب منكم
طلب اللي ينطبق عليه الكلام اللي انا
هقوله ده بليز
اللي ينطبق عليه الكلام اللي انا هقوله ده
يا ريت يفتح الفلاش بتاع موبايله ويقوم
يقف لو حد فيكم قبل كده على طول هتفتحي من
قبل ما نبدا ماشي لو حد فيكم قبل كده عمل
لنفسه خطه او بلان وما مشيتش زي ما هو
عايز يفتح الموبايل ويقوم يقف
اوكي لو حد قبل كده اتقال له كلمه وحشه عن
نفسه وصدقها يفتح الفلاش بتاع موبايله
ويقوم يقف
لو حد قبل كده قال لنفسه كلمه وحشه عن
نفسه
وصدقها يفتح الفلاش بتاع موبايله ويقوم
يقف
اسمحوا لي ان انا احكي لكم قصتي طبعا انا
عمري ما حكيت القصه دي قبل كده لحد وما
بعرفش احكي قصص قوي بس اسمحوا لي ان انا
احكي لكم قصتي وانا عندي 14 سنه خدت اهم
واول قرار في حياتي قررت ان انا عايز اخش
كليه طب طيب اشمعنى سنه 14 سنه ده مش سن
مميز مش وقت مميز وانا عندي 14 سنه جالنا
تليفون على البيت بيقول الو ياسين بابا
تعبان في المستشفى ومحتاج تروح تشوفه طبعا
انا ما كنتش فاهم اللي بيحصل كنت صغير كنت
فاكر ان عادي بابا تعبان هنروح نشوفه
هيروح رحت المستشفى وفاكر كل حاجه كانها
امبارح قالوا انها هتطلعوا الدور الرابع
تالت اوضه على الشمال تاني السويف كان اول
مره اشوف بابايا بالمنظر ده وانا مش قادر
اساعده وهو تعبان وفاكر الكلمه اللي قالها
الدكتور كويس قوي ما فيش حاجه في ايدينا
نقدر نعملها طبعا وهو بيقول كده الاهلي هو
ما بصليش ومهتمش بيا ممكن يكون عشان حاسس
ان انا كنت صغير او ان انا وجودي مش مهم
او ان الكلام ده مش هيفرق معي بس اللي هو
ما يعرفوش ان الجمله اللي هو قالها دي ما
فيش حاجه نقدر نعملها غيرت فيها كل حاجه
خلتني اقرر ان انا في يوم من الايام عايزه
ابقى دكتور واقف قدام طفل عنده 14 سنه
واقول له انت ممكن تاخد بابا وتروح رجعت
البيت وابتديت ادور وافهم ازاي الناس
بتبقى دكاتره وبيعملوا ايه وقررت فعلا ان
انا خلاص هسافر وهنجح وهوصل عشان في يوم
من الايام اقف في حلمي واوصل لحلمي
اشتغلت في المدرسه وجبت من اعلى الدرجات
خدت اكس عملت في كذا حته وقدمت على ست
جامعات في امريكا تمن جامعات في المانيا
جامعه في انجلترا 3 جامعات في سكاتلنت
واتقبلت في 15 جامعه من 18 جامعه اللي انا
قدمت فيهم ويسائل القدر th
روحش ولا واحده واخر جامعه قدمت فيها كليه
طب نيو جيزه في مصر هي الجامعه اللي انا
دخلتها طبعا رغم اني انا كنت راسم لنفسي
طريق ان انا هسيب كل حاجه وابدا حياه
جديده كل حاجه وكل حاجه هتبقى تمام ولكن
مش هتبقى في مصر وكان بالنسبه لي ان انا
اقعد في مصر ده اول طريق الفشل رغم اني
دخلت الجامعه اللي انا عايزها والكليه
اللي انا عايزها كليه توب بس كنت حسيت اني
فشلته وكان في صوت جوايا بيقول لي لا انت
ما عرفتش تعمل اللي انت كنت عايزه دخلت
والحمد لله نجحت في اول سنه وتاني سنه
دخلت قلت لا انا ما اتحطيتش على الطريق
اللي انا كنت عايزه انا فشلت مش هو ده كان
طريق مختلف تماما علشان انا مسافرتش وعملت
اللي انا كان نفسي فيه بس في تاني سنه
جالي اول اختبار حسسني ان التطبيق اللي
انا خدته ممكن مش هو اللي انا كنت عايزه
بس ممكن يكون طريق صح جالي تليفون تاني
الو ايوه ياسين ماما تعبانه ومش عارفه
تتكلم ومش مركزه تعال على البيت دلوقتي
حالا جريت من الجامعه على البيت دخلت لقيت
اخويا واقف مع مامتي وهي مش عارفه تتكلم
ومش فاهمه اللي بيحصل وكان بيجي لها جلطه
وفاكر بالظبط واخويا بيقول لماما خدي بس
يا ماما السيجاره دي وانت هتبقي كويسه
المشكله ان دي مش نكته والمشكله الاوحش ان
مامتي فعلا خدت سيجاره منه بس ساعتها عرفت
اتصرف وعرفت اعمل اخد مامتي المستشفى
واتحركت بيها واتكلمت مع الدكاتره وعرفت
اقف واكون الشخص اللي يقول لمامته انت
هتروحي معي النهارده اتحولت من شاب من طفل
عنده 14 سنه لشاب عنده 19 سنه عرف يعمل
حاجه صح
thank you
بس لسه كنت حسيت ان انا فشلت برده رغم ان
انا كنت على الطريق كان في مشاعر واحباط
وامل وحلم اتكسر انا ما كنتش عارف اتعامل
معه وعدت بها السنين وكنت بنجح لغايه ان
انا في يوم من الايام كنت قاعد مع صحابي
وكلهم مبسوطين وهم عندي في البيت وبنضحك
وانا ما كنتش موجود معهم نهائي كان لسه في
الفيلنس اللي انا ما عرفتش اتعامل معها
تاني يوم وانا بذاكر
طب علم النفس قريت كلمه وهي اللي غيرت كل
حاجه
جمله بسيطه جدا اعترف ان انت مش قادر وان
في حاجه غلط ساعتها قررت لا في حاجه غلط
انا مش كويس انا مش تمام انا لازم ابتدي
اغير من نفسي ابتريت اغير شويه واكتشفت
اسمه
الطريقه اللي بنفكر فيها بتاثر على
مشاعرنا وبالتالي بتاثر على افعالنا واللي
ياكد الكلام ده الفاوند فاضي بتاع امريكا
الاب الروحي لطب العلم النفسي في امريكا
لما قال
تويتر
البني ادم ممكن يغير حياته لو يغير
الطريقه اللي هو بيفكر فيها ويليام جيمس
بردو قال ان الطريقه اللي بنفكر فيها
بنبقى عملنا عادات معينه وتقاليد في المخ
وانا كنت شايف ان انا حطيت لنفسي احباط
وتشاؤم ودي العاده اللي انا كنت دخلت فيها
ابتديت
وبالمناسبه دي
انا عارف
على تليفوني
مقفوله
كلم نفسك كشخص انت بتحبه حاجه بسيطه جدا
كلنا عارفينها بس مش بنعملها لما يجي لنا
شخص احنا بنحبه متضايق احنا مش بندوس عليه
او بنضغط عليه او بنتك عليه زياده احنا
بنحتويه وبنحبه وبنكلمه بالراحه طيب ليه
ما بنعملش كده مع نفسنا ابتديت اعمل كده
ابطل اسمع الكلام اللي بقوله لنفسي واكلم
نفسي بالراحه واقنع نفسي حاجات تانيه
وابتديت اجرب حاجات كتير واشوف الحاجه من
طرق مختلفه ببساطه لو انا جبت دي
بس لو انا تلاته اربعه تنفع لو انا حطيتها
على الارض
ووقفت هنا هشوفها زي الشخص اللي قال رقم
اربعه بالعربي
لو انا حطيتها ووقفت هنا هشوفها حرف الام
او لو حد جعان فيكم ممكن يشوفها
لو انا وقفت هنا هشوفها تلاته ولو انا
وقفت هنا هشوفها ولو انا وقفت هنا مش
هشوفها خالص احنا بنبقى شايفين طريق واحد
وبنحطين لنفسنا رسميين طريق واحد هو ده
اللي هنمشي عليه وهو ده اللي احنا حاطينه
في مخنا وهو ده الصح بس الحقيقه ان انت
بتتحط في طرق كتير والدنيا مش بتمشي زي ما
انت عايز ولازم تختار الطريق اللي انت
اتحطيت فيه مش هو ده اللي انت حطيته في
مخك مش هو ده دايما هيبقى الطريق اللي انت
هتمشي فيه وان الطرق التانيه قدامك مفتوحه
كتير ساعتها لاحظت الواقع اللي انا كنت
فيه مش الخيال اللي انا كنت عايشه في مخي
او اسمه في مخي ان انا المفروض علشان انجح
ابقى درست بره واوصل اللي انا فيه انا
دلوقتي ياسين المحجوب في كليه طب سنه سته
في اخر سنه ليا ولما بصيت ورا اكتشفت ان
اول شخص اساعده هو مامتي واول عمليه
احضرها كانت الرباط الصليبي بتاع ابن اختي
واول شخص اقول له انت عندك كانسر واقف معه
لغايه لما يخف هو كان خالتي
اكتشفت ان ايه ده انا فعلا وصلت مش هو
الطريق اللي انا كنت عايزه بس انا وصلت
والمره دي كان طعمها احلى لان الناس اللي
انا قدرت اساعدهم هم كانوا اهلي واكتر ناس
انا بحبهم
وكانت اول مره امسك موبايلي واحط فيديو
اون لاين وانا بشتغل في اللعب بطبيعتي
وانا بحب نفسي واكتشفت ان انا لما حبيت
نفسي وحبيت اللي انا بعمله الناس برضو
حبتني وقدرت ان انا بعمله
وابتديت اعمل فيديوز اكتر واشارك للناس
حياتي اكتر واشارك للناس انا بعمله واجرب
ده واجرب ده واشوف الحاجه من كذا واقتنع
ان في كذا طريق ممكن ياخدك على الحته اللي
انت عايزها
وبقيت انا الشخص اللي بسببه ناس كتير قوي
اتطوعت في مستشفى 57 عشان انا اتطوعت بقيت
انا الشخص اللي الناس ابتدت تفهم ان كل
حياه وكل روح لها قيمه عشان انا انجست
بغبغان صغير وساعدته ان هو يمشي بقيت
ثانكيو بقيت من السيودنس اللي بقوا اول
ناس يعملوا ابحاث علميه في الجامعه بعد
لما انا كنت فاكر ان انا مش زيهم مش شاطر
زيهم ومش هنجحهم وبقيت الشخص اللي بشجع
الناس ان هم يتكلموا عن
صحتهم النفسيه علشان انا اتكلمت عن
الاكتئاب وان انا كنت بعاني بيه
اللي انا عايز اقوله ان انتم زي ما قلت
طرق كتير في مخكم وممكن تكونوا حاطين طريق
واحد هو ده اللي متخيلين ان هو هيوصلك على
اللي انت عايزه مش هو ده الطريق مش هي دي
الحاجه الوحيده في كذا طريقه هتتحط فيه
سيبك من الطريق اللي انت رسمته في مخك
اللي انت خايف انه هياخدك على الحته اللي
انت عايزها وقدر الطريق اللي انت موجود
فيه وما تحاولش تحفه في حاجه مقفوله
الحياه مش هتمشي زي ما احنا عايزين ولازم
نقدر ان هي لو ما مشيتش زي ما احنا عايزين
ممكن نمشي معها في طريق تاني ونوصل للي
احنا عايزين برضو وانا عارف ان الكلام
اللي انا بقوله اسهل من الفعل بكتير وان
في كتير مننا ممكن يكونوا خايفين انا كنت
خايفه قبل ما اجي هنا وكنت خايف قبل ما
امسك موبايلي كنت خايف قبل ما اعمل حاجات
كتير بس قبل ما اسيب المدرسه حد من
ادتني الكراسه دي اللي مكتوب عليها
الكراسه دي معايا بقى لها سبع سنين دلوقتي
وقبل ما اعمل اي حاجه وابص عليها لو
بتخوفك يمكن هي دي الحاجه اللي انت محتاج
تجربها
انا عارف ان الكلام اللي انا بقوله صعب
ممكن كتير ما يستوعبوش بس صدقوني لو انتم
فتحت مخكم وفتحت
واكتشفتوا ان ممكن نمشي في كذا طريق
الدنيا ممكن تمشي احسن ممكن توصل له اللي
انتم عايزينه وعايز اقول لكم لو انتم
خايفين او مش حاسين ان انتم هتوصلوا او مش
مقتنعين اعرفوا ان عادي ان احنا نبدا تاني
وعادي ان احنا نمشي في طريق تاني وممكن
نوصل وحتى لو اللي احنا ما حطيناهوش مخنا
هو اللي هيودينا الحته اللي احنا عايزينها
في كذا شكرا يا طياره في كذا طريقه ممكن
نوصل بيها ولو نسيته افتكروا نفسكوا
وانتوا واقفين قدامي سما مليانه نجوم مش
شخص واحد واقف على فلاش بيدور على حاجه
وان كل نجمه فيكم ليها قصه ومحتاجه تقسمها
ثانكيو
هقفل المايك بقى قبل ما افضى نفسي اقول
حاجه ثانيه